Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. So if you are downloading this fairly recently to when it was released, which is in March 2023, it probably hasn't escaped your knowledge that it is application notification season. So I am well aware that educational psychology interviews are already in full swing so if you are waiting to hear back on the outcome of one of those or if you are awaiting attending one of those yourself then wishing you all the very best of luck and there might well be useful information in here for you as well but of course it is declinesci, notification season currently. We are on the verge of interview season. So just to recap some of those important dates, we know that by the 17th of March, Clearinghouse and the associated courses must have let applicants know whether or not they
你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你是在节目发布后不久下载的（即2023年3月），那么你一定知道现在是申请通知季。我非常清楚教育心理学的面试已经全面展开，所以如果你正在等待面试结果，或者正在等待参加面试，祝你们好运。这里的内容对你可能也会有帮助，但当然，现在是拒绝通知季。我们正处于面试季的前夕。回顾一下那些重要的日期，我们知道到3月17日，Clearinghouse及相关课程必须通知申请人他们
will be invited to an interview for this year or whether they've been placed on a reserve list for an interview this year. It's always worth bearing in mind that if you are on the reserve list for an interview, you could be called even as soon as like that morning of the interview. So when it's interview week make sure your outfit is clean what you want to wear make sure that you know you've perhaps let people know in your diary that you might already have booked in for meetings supervision appointments that you're hoping there may be a chance you're called to interview because I really do believe in putting stuff out there in the universe. If you're kind of paving the way for potentially having an interview during a set week,
是否会被邀请参加今年的面试，或者是否被列入面试候补名单。请务必记住，即使你被列入候补名单，也可能在面试当天早上才接到通知。所以，在面试周期间，确保你的衣服干净整洁，确保你已经告知日程表上可能预定的会议或督导预约，因为你可能随时会被叫去面试。我真的相信要向宇宙发出信号。如果你正在为某一周可能进行的面试铺路，
then tell the universe that that is what you'd welcome. Don't be looking at your diary going, oh God, which day should it be? Which day would I have to cancel? You know, make sure that the people in each of your days know that, you know, you may have to cancel at short notice. If you're already working for the NHS, it's also worth bearing in mind that in theory, you don't need to take a day's annual leave to be able to attend an NHS interview. Because in essence, this is an NHS interview, you might then be able to keep your leave for something Because Inessence is an NHS interview, you might then be able to keep your leave for something that feels a bit more restful. Because, you know, I was gonna say you keep your leave for something a bit more exciting. But actually, I was really
那就告诉宇宙这是你所期待的。不要盯着日程表想：“天哪，应该是哪一天？哪一天我得取消？”你要确保你日程表上的相关人员知道，你可能需要临时取消行程。如果你已经在NHS工作，也请记住，理论上你不需要请年假去参加NHS的面试。因为本质上，这是一场NHS的面试，你或许可以把假期留给更放松的事情。因为，我本来想说你可以把假期留给更令人兴奋的事情。但实际上，我当时对
excited about both of the interview days that I had. You should be feeling, you know, a little bit, you're like, oh, this is a big deal. But also excited that you get to showcase, you get to show why you're so ready for this opportunity. And that's regardless of what you're going for an interview for, of course, you know. Whatever job you're going for, it ought to feel exciting. You know, you ought to feel like you've got a reasonable chance and that it's something that you would want, you know, so make sure that's the case.
我参加的两次面试都感到非常兴奋。你应该感到，你知道，这很重要。但同时也要为你能够展示自己、展示你为何如此胜任这个机会而感到兴奋。当然，无论你面试的是什么职位，都应该如此。无论你申请什么工作，都应该感到兴奋。你应该觉得你有合理的胜算，而且这是你真正想要的，所以请确保这一点。
So try and make sure that you do at least feel some excitement. It's not just abject horror. So you may well be listening to this aware that perhaps your first or maybe even your first couple of courses that you've applied to have notified you that it is a no first. It's really hard and I'm really sorry, I'm absolutely gutted for you. I also recall that the year that I was successful in getting on to training, I was actually told no first by the one course who weren't going to be offering me an interview so for those of you who don't know my story I was offered interviews at three other courses but one of the courses cancelled the entire course just before I was due to attend my interview so yeah if you go back into the annals of history you'll see that the
所以尽量确保你至少能感受到一些兴奋，而不只是极度的恐惧。你听这期节目时，可能已经知道你申请的第一门课程，甚至前几门课程已经通知你被拒绝了。这真的很艰难，我对此感到非常抱歉，我真的为你感到难过。我也记得我成功进入培训的那一年，我申请的唯一一门没有给我面试机会的课程也拒绝了我。所以对于那些不知道我故事的人，我当时收到了其他三门课程的面试邀请，但其中一门课程在我参加面试前就取消了整个课程。所以，如果你回顾历史，你会发现
2008 intake for the Bristol course um didn't go ahead at all um and then I think it actually moved to Plymouth ultimately but um yes I was potentially part of that cohort if I'd been interviewed because I do wonder I did really like Bristol I was telling one of my friends who lives in Bristol recently I really like Bristol I may have picked I may have picked Bristol had they offered me a place had that gone ahead but I'm very very pleased with where I did end up and you know when you're in a position where you do have multiple interviews at different courses we have this sort of butterfly effect you know that it's quite a big decision which course you'll be at because it could potentially lead to what future
2008年布里斯托尔课程的招生根本没有进行，后来好像最终搬到了普利茅斯。但是的，如果我当时被面试了，我可能就是那一届的学生。我确实很喜欢布里斯托尔，我最近告诉一位住在布里斯托尔的朋友，我真的很喜欢那里。如果他们录取了我，我可能真的会选择布里斯托尔。但我对自己最终去的地方非常非常满意。当你同时获得多个课程的面试机会时，会有某种“蝴蝶效应”，因为选择去哪门课程是一个重大的决定，它可能会决定你未来的
job you'll be in who you're it will definitely lead to who your future supervisors will be who your future cohort will be in my case it led to the creation of two wonderful little boys and a marriage, you know, and friendship groups and in-laws and all of that jazz. So it is really can be a life changing decision, especially if you're doing that at an age point where you do have more choices, you know, where you could end up going to Scotland, you could end up going to Wales, you could end up going to Wales, you could end up going, you know, to the south of England or to middle England, you know. If you are more footloose and fancy free, then these decisions, the ones you say yes to, or the ones who say yes to you, can be life changing. And that can be exciting, but can also be a little bit terrifying too. So
工作，决定你未来的督导是谁，决定你未来的同学是谁。就我而言，它促成了两个可爱小男孩的出生、一段婚姻、朋友圈、姻亲等等。所以这确实是一个改变人生的决定，特别是如果你在有更多选择的年龄段做这个决定时，比如你可以去苏格兰、威尔士、英格兰南部或中部。如果你更自由自在，那么这些决定——你答应的，或者答应你的——可能会改变你的人生。这既令人兴奋，也可能有点可怕。所以
anyway, we're wandering off track. But I want to empathize with anybody who has so far received no or not yet as we think about them think about it as not yet or not right now and if you've applied to more than one course then you might well get reserve list places for other interviews or you might well get outright interview offers as well for other courses so I am sending you so much hope so much so many crossed fingers that that happens for you um but yeah if it helps my first envelope that I opened because in those days they were envelopes my first envelope that I opened in 2008 which was the year that I opened, because in those days they were envelopes, my first envelope that I opened in 2008, which was the year that I was successful, was a no. So please hold on to that if that feels useful. And you might be in the position that you are told no, no, no, no, if you've applied to four places. And that doesn't mean that you're not good enough. It means that you're lovely. It cohort when you're doing this role when you
总之，我们跑题了。但我想要同情那些目前收到“拒绝”或“暂不”通知的人，我们把它看作是“还不是时候”或“目前不行”。如果你申请了不止一门课程，你很可能会收到其他面试的候补名单通知，或者直接收到其他课程的面试邀请。所以我为你送上满满的希望，祈祷这一切能发生。但如果这有帮助的话，我2008年打开的第一个信封（那时候还是纸质信封），也就是我成功的那一年，结果是拒绝。所以如果觉得有用，请记住这一点。如果你申请了四个地方，结果都被拒绝了，那并不意味着你不够好。这意味着你很可爱。当你担任这个角色时，当你
are wearing that name badge that says trainee clinical psychologist or trainee educational psychologist or you know trainee forensic psychologist whatever element you want to do we want you to feel ready and to be able to do this job well with all of the necessary skills that you need to have on board and online to help you to fly and help your clients to really soar too. So I'm going to cover some interview stuff that might be useful to consider in this episode but I'm not going to be repeating the stuff from podcast episode 10, which was released on Valentine's Day last year, so 14th of February 2022, and that episode is called How to Optimally Prepare for an Interview as an Asp. So if you go to the show on either Apple podcast or Spotify or
戴着写有“临床心理学实习生”、“教育心理学实习生”或“法医心理学实习生”的名牌时，我们希望你感到准备就绪，并能运用所有必要的技能出色地完成工作，帮助你展翅高飞，也帮助你的客户翱翔。所以，我将在本期节目中涵盖一些面试中值得考虑的内容，但我不会重复播客第10期的内容（那是去年情人节，即2022年2月14日发布的），那期节目叫《如何为心理学面试做好最佳准备》。所以，如果你去Apple Podcast或Spotify，或者
even YouTube for that matter and search for episode 10 or ep 10 it will be on YouTube aspiring psychologist podcast or type in how to optimally prepare you should find it there is a link in the show notes and this is going to be additional stuff. But since we launched that episode, of course, on the 28th of February last year, we launched the Aspiring Psychologist membership too. And that's a really useful way of covering lots of forward slash most of all of the areas that I'm going to be outlining in this episode. So if you feel like it's your time and you're ready for a little bit of coaching, a little bit of helping you feel more confident in your abilities, helping you practice some of these key skills and experiences,
甚至是YouTube上搜索第10期或“ep 10”，你就能在YouTube的《有抱负的心理学家》播客中找到它，或者输入“如何做好最佳准备”，你应该能找到。节目说明里有链接，而这期节目将提供额外的内容。但自从我们发布那期节目后，我们在去年2月28日也推出了“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”。这是涵盖我将在本期节目中概述的大部分领域的一个非常有用的方式。所以，如果你觉得时机已到，准备好接受一点辅导，帮助你对自己能力更有信心，帮助你练习一些关键技能和经验，
then do please come on board to the As psychologist membership it's 30 pounds a month and you can leave anytime you like there's no minimum requirement to stay so so do come on board and let us help you to reach your goals but we also of course have free content so we do have the free compassionate q a so let me just talk you through the dates that we've got coming up for those. Okay, so if you're watching on YouTube, or even if you're not, please do take a note of these dates for your diary for the free Q&A sessions, compassionate Q&A sessions, which will be running across all of my socials. A really great place to catch that is in the free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent Brackett's free group. So make sure you've requested access to that in good time. But it will also be running on Twitter, LinkedIn, YouTube and Facebook page as well. If I have the battery power and Instagram is behaving, it will also be running on Instagram Live as well. But I won't be able to access the comments on Instagram Live. And also
那么请加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”。每月30英镑，你可以随时退出，没有最低期限要求。所以请加入我们，让我们帮助你实现目标。当然，我们也有免费内容，比如免费的“同理心问答”。让我来告诉你接下来的日期。好的，如果你正在看YouTube，或者即使没有，也请记下这些免费问答环节的日期，这些环节将在我的所有社交媒体上进行。一个很好的参与地点是免费的Facebook群组，即“Dr. Marianne Trent的心理学抱负社区（免费群组）”。所以请务必提前申请加入。它也会在Twitter、LinkedIn、YouTube和Facebook页面上进行。如果电池电量充足且Instagram运行正常，它也会在Instagram Live上进行。但我无法查看Instagram Live上的评论。而且
it's worth bearing in mind, I can't usually access the Twitter comments either, just because of a random quirk in Twitter, that when I'm streaming via StreamYard, it doesn't access the comments. So you can join me on Monday, the 13th of March, 2023 at 7.30pm. That's number one. Monday, the 17th of April, 2023 at 7.30pm. And then just as a little bit of a change, because of a bank holiday, we've got Tuesday, the 2nd of May, 7 30 p.m and in the past they've been really intimate really nice sessions where you're able to bring any of your or any of your more focused questions and we can help think about what might be really useful what might help you look
值得注意的是，我通常也无法查看Twitter的评论，因为Twitter的一个随机特性，当我通过StreamYard直播时，它无法访问评论。所以你可以在2023年3月13日星期一晚上7:30加入我。这是第一场。2023年4月17日星期一晚上7:30是第二场。然后，因为银行假日，我们做了一点调整，时间定在5月2日星期二晚上7:30。过去这些都是非常亲密、非常好的环节，你可以提出任何你更关注的问题，我们可以一起思考什么可能真的有用，什么可能帮助你
after yourself right now what might what might help you bring your best to your what might help you bring your a game so that you're more likely to get your goal so I do hope you find those sessions really useful do remember on YouTube you can also watch previous sessions that we've run in the compassionate Q&A series by heading to the playlist. And again, I'll pop a link to that in the show notes. Other ways that people have found really useful for preparing for interviews is the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. There's really useful examples in there of how people have reflected upon their development and their own experiences. And of course, since last year, we've had the
照顾好自己，什么可能帮助你发挥出最佳水平，从而更有可能实现你的目标。所以我希望你觉得这些环节真的很有用。请记住，在YouTube上，你也可以通过播放列表观看我们之前举办的“同理心问答”系列节目。同样，我会在节目说明中放一个链接。人们发现非常有用的另一种面试准备方式是《临床心理学家集体》这本书。里面有非常有用的例子，展示了人们如何反思自己的发展和个人经历。当然，自去年以来，我们有了
birth of a new baby book. We've had the birth of the aspiring psychologist collective book as well. And that's a really nice demonstration of other people's reflection and growth experiences as well. So yeah, dig out those books if you've got a copy and consider grabbing a copy if you don't yet have one because people do speak really highly of them. Okay, so broadly speaking, we're looking at breaking down our presentation today into a number of different sections. We're looking at personal issues and reflections, professional issues and reflections, clinical issues and reflections, and research issues and reflections. So in terms of our clinical skills and reflections, it's always really useful to be able to demonstrate and to quickly conjure up formulations for clients or staff teams or other groups you've worked with from two different perspectives. It might be CBT, it might be CAT, it might be psychodynamic, it might be systemic, it might be DBT, it could be
一本新书的诞生。我们有了《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书。这也是展示他人反思和成长经历的一个很好的例子。所以，如果你有这本书，请把它找出来；如果你还没有，考虑买一本，因为人们对它的评价非常高。好的，总的来说，我们今天将把演讲分为几个不同的部分：个人问题与反思、专业问题与反思、临床问题与反思，以及研究问题与反思。在临床技能和反思方面，能够展示并快速为客户、员工团队或其他你合作过的群体构思出两种不同视角的案例概念化（formulation）总是非常有用的。可能是CBT、CAT、心理动力学、系统论、DBT，或者是
any model that you're familiar with working with that you can demonstrate in the moment, an aptitude to be able to talk confidently about, you know, what is contributing to the client's difficulties, how you've understood them, what might be perpetuating them, all of that jazz, to be able to demonstrate that to the people that you will meet at interview. But also, even if you don't do that, just to hold that in your pocket and be able to pop out the word formulation can be really useful it's useful to be able to reflect on what the clinical work brings up for you currently or what it's brought up for you in the past can be really useful to do that within supervision and do remember if you haven't yet grabbed my free supervision shaping tool you can do that by going to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision and that will come to you and that might really help shape your supervision
任何你熟悉的模型，你都能在当下展示出自信谈论的能力，比如是什么导致了客户的困难，你是如何理解他们的，什么可能在维持这些困难，所有这些。能够向面试官展示这一点。但即使你不这样做，仅仅把“案例概念化”这个词放在口袋里随时拿出来用也是非常有用的。能够反思临床工作目前为你带来了什么，或者过去为你带来了什么，在督导中进行反思是非常有用的。请记住，如果你还没有领取我免费的“督导塑造工具”，你可以通过访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision 来获取，这可能会真正帮助你塑造
relationships with your supervisor or with even people that you supervise now or in future so it's well worth registering for that and it's totally free so yeah it could help you to think about how to use supervision and how to give effective clinical supervision too. So it can be really useful to have conversations around some of this clinical stuff and around your own diversity, your own inclusion, the clients you work with and all of that jazz in supervision. So I hope that's useful for you in that realm. And of course, we go on to the research section as well. So you need to be able to talk, you know, with ease about research without pulling that face, you know, so that you've got an overview of statistical
你与督导的关系，或者与你现在或未来督导的人的关系。所以非常值得注册，而且完全免费。所以是的，它可以帮助你思考如何利用督导，以及如何提供有效的临床督导。因此，围绕这些临床内容，以及你自己的多样性、包容性、你合作的客户等进行对话是非常有用的。所以我希望这对你在该领域有所帮助。当然，我们也会进入研究部分。你需要能够轻松地谈论研究，而不会露出那种表情，这样你就能对统计学有一个概述，
models and measures and tests that you might use so that you understand when you might want to use quantitative versus qualitative or vice versa. So that you are able to, you know, critically appraise other people's research and your own research and also think about gaps in the research knowledge base and what you might want to explore in future or what you think might be useful to explore in future. That might well be stuff from your own clinical population that you're working in, that's okay, but you need to have an overview of what research is already out there and be able to talk confidently about what stuff you think would be useful in future and how and why you might investigate it or put that together
了解你可能使用的模型、测量方法和测试，这样你就知道什么时候该用定量研究，什么时候该用定性研究，反之亦然。这样你就能批判性地评估他人的研究和你自己的研究，并思考研究知识库中的空白，以及你未来可能想探索什么，或者你认为未来探索什么是有用的。这可能来自你正在工作的临床人群，这没问题，但你需要对现有的研究有一个概述，并能自信地谈论你认为未来什么是有用的，以及你如何以及为什么可能去调查它或将其整合在一起。
so have a play around with that and again that's stuff that we do do in the membership and that you can catch up on as well so having a working knowledge of research methods is really useful um you know what what is what is grounded theory what is ipa you know why would you use um a randomized control trial you know why what is that even um having a little look at refreshing your memory on on that sort of background can be really useful and if listening to this makes you go and suck in your teeth then it's okay to embrace what scares you you know it's okay to turn towards that so that it's not such a weak Achilles heel for you so that it feels like you're strengthening your suit of armor to have fewer chinks in it and fewer you know fewer really spots that feel very
所以去尝试一下吧，这也是我们在会员计划中会做的内容，你也可以补课。拥有研究方法的工作知识非常有用。你知道什么是扎根理论，什么是IPA，你为什么要使用随机对照试验，那到底是什么。稍微回顾一下这方面的背景知识会非常有用。如果听这些让你感到牙疼，那么拥抱让你害怕的东西也没关系。转向它，这样它就不会成为你的阿喀琉斯之踵，这样你就能加强你的盔甲，减少裂缝，减少那些让你感到非常
tender that if someone pokes it you're not going to go too much so that you feel ready it's your time and you're ready for this next step why even is research important why do we champion it why do we do it why do we think it's useful? Having your own individual stance on that can be really useful too. So professional issues as well, you know, why are we doing this as such a robust clinical process? You know why why does clinical psychology exist you know what is it um how can we help maximize its availability for more people um how can we use supervision or management supervision effectively to think about the way in which we're doing leadership the way in which we're you know looking after nurturing the team to be able to spread the knowledge and the impact of
脆弱、一碰就疼的地方。这样你就会感到准备好了，这是你的时刻，你已经为下一步做好了准备。为什么研究很重要？我们为什么要支持它？我们为什么要这样做？我们为什么认为它有用？拥有自己对此的个人立场也非常有用。还有专业问题，我们为什么要进行这样一个稳健的临床过程？临床心理学为什么存在？它是什么？我们如何帮助更多人最大限度地获得它？我们如何有效地利用督导或管理督导来思考我们的领导方式，我们如何照顾和培养团队，以便传播知识和影响力？
what we do in the psychology team far and wide to reach a wider audience what acts are there that govern the work we do so having a little bit of a knowledge of those can be really useful too. At this point, let's break for a short moment and I'll be back very soon. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
我们在心理学团队中所做的工作，传播到更广的范围，以触及更广泛的受众。有哪些法案管理着我们的工作？所以了解一点这些知识也非常有用。现在，让我们休息片刻，我很快就会回来。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。充满经验和教训，将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Hello, my name is Veronika Kasova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a Masters in Psychology of Mental Health. Marian recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread
这就是《临床心理学家集体》。你好，我叫Veronika Kasova。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在LinkedIn上建立人脉时，Marian向我推荐了《临床心理学家集体》，我必须说我爱死它了。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让你看到那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙述才能揭示的无形智慧。一个共同点
in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others but with myself too. Also not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, grow and the final results will come as a byproduct. Marianne, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. Thank you. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
在我最珍视的故事中，就是要不仅对他人，也要对自己保持同情。此外，不要执着于成为心理学家，而是享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然到来。Marianne，感谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。谢谢。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。这就是《临床心理学家集体》。
Welcome back. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh If you're watching on YouTube, you probably should be clicking subscribe and liking this episode at the very least if you're still watching. If you're listening on Spotify, please do subscribe. And the same for Apple as well. Wherever you're watching, you know, please do subscribe. And if you're listening on Apple podcast, please do rate and review us. It just takes a moment, but it means a great deal. Our personal. Why are we doing what we do why do you want to do what you do what turned your head towards it in the first place um thinking about you know our own social graces those of the clients we're working with if you're not familiar with the work of Social Graces, give John Burnham a quick Google and get yourself back up to speed with those.
欢迎回来。如果你正在看YouTube，如果你还在看，至少应该点击订阅并点赞这期节目。如果你在Spotify上收听，请务必订阅。Apple也是一样。无论你在哪里观看，请务必订阅。如果你在Apple Podcast上收听，请评分和评论。这只需要一点时间，但意义重大。关于个人：我们为什么要从事我们所做的工作？你为什么想做你所做的事？当初是什么让你转向它？思考我们自己的社交礼仪，以及我们合作客户的社交礼仪。如果你不熟悉“社交礼仪”（Social Graces）的工作，去谷歌搜索一下John Burnham，让自己跟上进度。
And if you can, please do think about having a mock interview. Ideally, with your supervisor would be really useful. But with another qualified clinician, if you're not supervised by a clinical psychologist or an educational psychologist, a forensic psychologist, any kind of qualified psychologist is really useful. And it helps you get those tumbleweed moments out and they're done so that you feel less horrified. And it's also really useful to think about recording yourself. And that is something I spoke about in the last podcast episode, episode 10, well worth a listen, because people find that really, really useful. So yeah, listen to yourself, get used to the sound of you talking about you and knowing that's okay. If you're not yet in the position where you've been offered interviews or if by the time you listen to this episode you have been made aware that you have been given four no thanks not yet um then please try not to lose hope this process does start again before we know it and by that point you'll
如果可以，请考虑进行一次模拟面试。理想情况下，与你的督导进行模拟面试会非常有用。但如果你的督导不是临床心理学家、教育心理学家或法医心理学家，那么与任何其他合格的心理学家进行模拟面试也非常有用。这有助于你克服那些尴尬的时刻，让你不再感到惊恐。录下自己的表现也非常有用。这是我在上一期播客（第10期）中提到的，非常值得一听，因为人们发现这真的非常有帮助。所以，听听自己的声音，习惯自己谈论自己的声音，并知道这没关系。如果你还没有获得面试机会，或者当你听到这期节目时，你已经被告知收到了四个“不，谢谢，还不是时候”，那么请尽量不要失去希望。这个过程很快就会重新开始，到那时你
have another six months solid experience and how can you use this next six months to really make sure that by this time next year you're getting one two three maybe even four yes please we'd like you to tell us more about yourself opportunities. And if you do have, you know, your one lucky chance, if you do have your one golden ticket, then please know that's all you need. That's all you need. If it's your time and it's the right course for you and I don't know, the sun is shining in the right direction and all seems to be going well and the traffic lights are all green on your way there to the interview and you're able to bring your A game
将会有另外六个月扎实的经验。你如何利用接下来的六个月，确保明年这个时候你能收到一、二、三，甚至四个“是的，请告诉我们更多关于你的信息”的机会？如果你确实有你的那一次幸运机会，如果你确实有你的那张金奖券，那么请知道这就是你所需要的。这就是你所需要的。如果时机到了，这是适合你的课程，而且我不知道，太阳正朝着正确的方向照耀，一切似乎都很顺利，去面试的路上红绿灯都是绿灯，而且你能够发挥出最佳水平
to that interview day then that's all you need you know you do just need one university to allow you to have an interview to be able to demonstrate why this is a great fit for you while this course is great for you and how it is your time and you're ready for the next step so please be kind to yourselves please be really kind and supportive to those around you as well because this can be a really triggering time um and it's also it's okay to be sad for yourself and excited for others or vice versa it's okay to be really sad that your colleagues or friends might not be getting interviews but also be really proud and excited about your own interviews that you have lined up so yeah please do stay kind if you do consider coming on board to the aspiring psychologist
在那一天的面试中，那么这就是你所需要的。你只需要一所大学给你面试机会，让你展示为什么这非常适合你，为什么这门课程非常适合你，以及为什么现在是你的时刻，你已经准备好迈出下一步了。所以请善待自己，也请善待和支持你周围的人，因为这可能是一个非常容易触发情绪的时期。对自己感到难过，同时为他人感到兴奋（反之亦然）也没关系。因为同事或朋友可能没有获得面试机会而感到难过，同时为自己安排好的面试感到自豪和兴奋，这完全没问题。所以请保持善良。如果你确实考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家”
membership if you feel that might be useful for a little bit more bespoke skills advice and support from qualified clinicians who want to help you advance your confidence then you can check out details in the show notes or by going to the link in any of my social media bios but yeah thank you for joining me do check out episode 10 of the aspiring psychologist podcast for further optimal interview prep tips do let me know won't you how you get on with your outcomes and remember I will just go through them again with you remember to join us for the free compassionate q and a sessions which will be running across my socials you can find me dr marianne trent pretty much everywhere
会员计划，如果你觉得这可能对获得更多量身定制的技能建议和支持有用，来自那些想帮助你提升信心的合格临床医生，那么你可以查看节目说明中的详细信息，或者通过我任何社交媒体简介中的链接。但谢谢你加入我。请查看《有抱负的心理学家》播客的第10期，获取更多最佳面试准备技巧。请一定要告诉我你的结果如何。记住，我会再和你过一遍，记得加入我们的免费“同理心问答”环节，这些环节将在我的社交媒体上进行。你可以找到我，Dr. Marianne Trent，几乎在所有地方。
on monday the 13th of march 2023 7 30 p.m monday the 17th of april 2023 7 30 p.m and Tuesday the 2nd of May 2023 also at 7 30 p.m. Thank you so much for joining me like subscribe do all those good things tell your friends about us and I'll look forward to catching up with you for the next podcast episode which will be coming to you from 6 a.m on Monday. Take care. Thanks for being part of my world. things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
2023年3月13日星期一晚上7:30，2023年4月17日星期一晚上7:30，以及2023年5月2日星期二晚上7:30。非常感谢你的加入，点赞、订阅，做所有那些好事，告诉你的朋友们关于我们的事。我期待在下一期播客中与你见面，节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。你可以尝试的事情。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything
我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，没有完美的途径，这让我充满信心，觉得我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，让你感到安心，一切
will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。